uh please disable joined once again on
the program by the former Chief of
general staff Lord Daniel very good
morning to you um and I wonder if we
could start with with that which we were
just hearing once again indeed we were
discussing this last time you were on
the program the Russians continuing to
Target civilian infrastructure in this
way but but as you said last time you
know the ukrainians aren't going to be
aren't going to be running as a result
of just this
well I think that's right
um Putin is continuing his pressure on
the Ukrainian people
um we've seen continuing attacks on
their core National infrastructure and
of course that is now having the effect
of the pictures that you've just shown
of people queuing for for water
electricity has been hit really badly
and of course that feeds through the
pumping stations and therefore you get
water shortages and so on but um if he
thinks that he's going to break the
Ukrainian people's will
um I think most commentators all
commentators
um would actually agree that this is
just not going to work uh the ukrainians
are very committed their soldiers are
committed on the battlefield and their
civilians are committed in their cities
and towns and of course it's interesting
to reflect on the battlefield because
the fight around Kirsten is intensifying
uh it would appear that the Russians
have moved some of their better troops
to defend kurzon and if it was to be
lost it's a major major defeat major
embarrassment for put on for Putin as
Curson is the one major city that he's
managed to capture so far so on the
battlefield the Fight Continues and home
the Fight Continues
and it also appears to be continuing in
cyberspace I wonder what your your
viewers Lord Donna of the significance
of the fact that the UK is now providing
well significant assistance in defending
uh the Ukraine cyberspace
well of course one of the interesting
things is that the British government
has felt this was the right time to talk
about these things publicly no bad thing
to do that but it does underline that we
as a nation are very much continuing to
support Ukraine the teams from gchq and
the UK National cyber security Center
undoubtedly have been working hand in
glove with the ukrainians to defeat
Russian cyber attacks and that's only
right and proper and of course the fact
is no surprise that uh the sfb and other
Russian intelligence Services should
have been trying to penetrate Ukraine's
governmental system and of course that
was all part of what they were trying to
do before Putin launched his ground
attack on the 24th of February he and
his agents were trying to undermine the
Ukrainian government so that hopefully
when there was a push down from Belarus
with their armored columns the
government in key would crumble well we
know that didn't happen and one of the
reasons we now know that it didn't
happen was that the UK was significantly
helping with the counter cyber attack a
process and I think great credit to our
cyber security people for doing that do
you detect perhaps a degree of
frustration perhaps even desperation
creeping into the tactics deployed by
Vladimir Putin I know this morning from
the mod uh the movement of some
significant material to Belarus which
seems more a statement towards the West
rather than the intent to use it in
Ukraine
well Putin is becoming desperate because
there is no other way to look at what's
going on the battlefield other than to
to say that he is doing really poorly
um the attack in the north a few weeks
ago on the car keys front and it was
really embarrassing for the Russian
military I mean they fell back in in
disarray so he is trying to do other
things to improve his own position to
cause confusion and this movement
apparent movement of some troops into
Belarus is an interesting one
um I don't think that there's hard
evidence of combat units moving there
such that they could try and make
another strike south from Belarus to
Kiev I think this is um part of a
confusing picture he wants to build up
to try and bring some confusion uh to uh
analyst in in the West
I think the other thing is worth just
reflecting on we talked a number of
months ago about how healthy or not
Vladimir Putin was
um observed Keen observers now are
noting that um his hands are looking
pretty black on top which is a sign of
uh injections going in when other parts
of the body can't take injections it's
um interesting to note that and just to
watch whether he is as Fit and Well as
he would like to portray
um it's an interesting area to keep an
eye on indeed out Lord Daniel I know
that we have to let you go but I can't
do so without first congratulating you
that wonderful poppy cushion just over
your left shoulder there thanks so much
for your time always good to see you